that's Katie arriving in an LA Court  this morning looking all business in a  lime green pantsuit this is Katie's  second day in court yesterday she was  all smiles despite being a defendant in  a copyright infringement lawsuit at  issue her 2013 hit Dark Horse a  grammy-nominated Christian rapper who  goes by the name flame claims Katie  stole the beat from his 2008 song joyful  [Music]  milady and the other composers of Dark  Horse say they had never heard of the  rapper or his song and today Katie took  the stand the trial is expected to last  two weeks you know what it is  so is Katie worried doesn't look like it  before court she in Orlando went on a  bike date with their doggie nugget  sleeping ready and will be with Katie's  man this weekend at Comic Con he's  promoting his new fantasy Amazon Series  carnival row  thank you delivering apply  [Music]